[Música]
el ex presidente de eeuu o donald trump
buscaría volver a llegar a la casa
blanca aunque por ahora no hay un
anuncio oficial por parte del ex
mandatario este anuncio podría entonces
llegar antes de las elecciones de medio
término del mes de noviembre en las que
el presidente joe biden se juega a las
mayorías demócratas en ambas cámaras del
congreso el regreso de donald trump de
la política no sería una sorpresa en los
últimos meses el ex presidente ha
multiplicado sus actos públicos ha
también recaudado cientos de millones de
dólares en donaciones y ha impulsado con
un cierto grado de éxito a candidatos
afines a sus ideas políticas para estos
comicios todo esto en medio de las
audiencias del comité el congreso de
eeuu donde se busca esclarecer la toma
el capítulo del seminario del 21 además
de implicación del ex presidente de
trump en estos hechos saludamos entonces
a nuestra primera invitada al día ya
sana maría salazar analista política
especializada en temas de seguridad y ex
subsecretaria adjunta en el pentágono
gracias anamaría por estar con nosotros
esta mañana directo américa de france 24
para nosotros realmente es un gusto
qué tan muy buenos días muchos saludos
desde la ciudad de mexico y señora ana
maría ya digamos no se trata de un tema
si se va a lanzar sino de cuándo cree
entonces usted armaría que unan trump
para anunciar estas intenciones
presidenciales antes o después de la de
las elecciones de medio término del mes
de noviembre
mira yo creo que si hay muchas
posibilidades de que si no se lanza
abiertamente se declara como candidato o
lo menos va a tener
una serie de eventos de aquí a noviembre
en donde él buscaría usar la ola de las
de las campañas de los republicanos para
subirse él a esa ola y ya empezar a
hablar como un candidato presidencial
sería lo más lógico o sea aprovechar las
elecciones intermedias de medio término
para lanzar su candidatura y estar
haciendo campaña ya sea para el 1 a
favor de los candidatos republicanos que
el apoyo claro obviamente esto digamos
reforzaría la fuerza que han tenido los
republicanos en lo que han sido las
elecciones no en cada estado y también
qué tan delicado sería esto para el
presidente yo bailé ni los demócratas de
cara a estas elecciones teniendo en
cuenta que la popularidad el presidente
no está también en este momento
mira muy interesante tu pregunta porque
podrían suceder dos fenómenos uno que se
fortaleciera la candidatura de don otro
y al empezar a hacer campaña en este
momento apoyando a estos republicanos
pero al mismo tiempo dependiendo de la
presión o la visión que se tenga de
todos nosotros de lo que sucedió el 10
de enero podría debilitar a algunos
candidatos o sea es una es un cuchillo
de doble filo en el caso de iovine en
mira yo yo pondría parte en el tema de
haydn de este fenómeno de trump porque
yo bailén tiene inherentemente un
problema no solamente control sino
inherentemente con el partido demócrata
en donde más del 64% de los encuestados
dicen que no quieren que sea el
candidato demócrata entonces yo creo que
hay que cómo separar estos dos fenómenos
porque aunque donald trump no sea el
candidato o si sea el candidato el baile
no tiene que preocuparse más en este
momento de fortalecer su imagen como
presidente que este nivel está ahorita
33 por ciento de popularidad y además
buscar que es tenga una aceptación por
su partido el partido demócrata claro y
digamos que también la tendría difícil
el presidente yo bailé no de cara a
estas elecciones de 2024 otras cosas
pues por sus políticas que no han calado
muy bien en la sociedad estadounidense
por el fenómeno trump que evidentemente
está con fuerza en eeuu con sus
seguidores digamos firmes pero el
partido demócrata para estas elecciones
de 1024 no tendrían todavía como un
candidato fuerte no para poder competir
en este caso si es que confirma a donald
trump en su candidatura para el 2024
entonces que tendría que hacer el
partido demócrata y quien podría ser si
no es el presidente joe biden para poder
digamos competir con un candidato tan
fuerte como lo es el expresidente donald
trump
mira yo creo que en parte va a depender
si en verdad donald trump es el
candidato si ya en bastante certeza de
que va a ser el candidato
acordate todavía faltan dos años más de
dos años y meses para las elecciones
presidenciales entonces pero en parte
depende si don otto no para acaba siendo
el candidato no de la forma que podría
irse calando o se podría ir decantando
por donde quién va a ser candidato por
parte de los republicanos es la
candidata natural
debería
anamaría no sé si me escuchas creo que
tenemos como problemas en la conexión y
ya tenemos otra vez
si no te comentaba de que la candidata
no sea natural debería de ser la
vicepresidenta cámara que eres pero
también tiene ya problemas y fricciones
en su con el partido con los demócratas
pues también estaría por verse claro y
además la presidenta cámara abrirse
tampoco en este momento digamos ha
contado con una gran popularidad y pues
hay muchas críticas que el rol digamos
como llegó con tanta fuerza a la
vicepresidencia de ese país es como
hitos históricamente una mujer
afrodescendiente a la puesta la silla de
la vicepresidenta del país pues como que
no has empeñado y no ha hecho como que
mayores cambios dentro de eso no pero na
maria volviendo digamos rápidamente
antes de finalizar en nuestra
conversación con él el comité del del
congreso sobre el capitolio el lo que
pasó del 6 de enero exactamente
esto pareciera que no ha debilitado a
los al partido republicano y tampoco la
imagen del ex presidente una trump
digamos como lo usted cómo va a quedar
toda esta audiencia y toda esta
investigación
mira siguiendo muy de cerca lo que está
pasando el comité parte del problema es
que si están surgiendo información y
evidencia bastante contundente que
vinculan a donald trump con esta con
esta insurrección aquí la interrogante
que hay que seguir los dientes meses es
que si van a abrirle un proceso penal en
contra el presiente don ottón que
podrían concluir una acusación de
insurrección que implicaría que si se
encuentra culpable no puede ser
candidato a la presidencia entonces por
eso te digo faltan dos casitas de dos
años me suele pasar en dos años